or the regular blackouts
divide and conquer
where I live
you are told not to eat from the neighbour's house
and if you have nice enough colleagues
South Africans
that is specifically prepared for you emncimbini
who own several Afro shops
you can go to this restaurant
um you have accommodation
but if you're South African living abroad
they are part of my personal community
like people who are not necessarily your friends personally
personally I do have friends in Hamburg who are South African
perhaps even consciously
but that's just like
and you form a network
of Nigerians
and I've heard that there is a community there
Nigerians who or
those are going to be your first community
a Senegalese person
think about how when you're a kid
and you get to know them
they will even have
of Zimbabweans
in the area to a wedding
I'm curious share with us your experience
and you commune with them
living in Germany for over a decade
a lot of us were socialised not to trust each other
and I think all of this socialisation
or people from Ivory Coast
and I think that's what happens with a lot of South Africans
so the South Africans who are emigrating are generally doing it just
they are going to want to show you around
the vast inequality
South Africans in Germany
now this means that as
you generally already have some security
someone might suggest that we meet up for a braai in the summer
and you meet other Nigerians
and some people are even emigrating because they fell in love with someone
or Nigerian person
on the other hand
in comparison to
just for vibes
they host events that are centred around their communities and their culture
or to a child's baptism
but that's very different from being a part of the South African community
or the Ghana Independence Day annual Celebration
I think another reason South Africans do not prioritise
and you're taught also not to share your plans and your goals with other people
distrusting of other South Africans
we just don't feel like we need to create a community with them
let's say Ghanaians
working and teaching English in Asia
it makes us subconsciously
they doing it because they wanna experience something new
so despite the high unemployment rate
or because they received a scholarship
for example in Hamburg
so you do not feel the need to reach out and seek a South African community
and other African nationals
South Africans are still not desperate enough to seek a better life
and very often
we might be a part of
if you craving a traditional food
it's not hosted by South Africans
and she's absolutely right
and they want to be with them
forming community with other South Africans is because of our history
so at a family event
outside of South Africa
but they are not part of the South African community
of Senegalese
or there'll be
or South Africans in Europe
now I think this conversation might exclude South Africans
do you have a community of South Africans
but they are part of the community of South Africans where you live
I might see a poster on the wall
around here in Hamburg
this is very different from the other African nationals here in Germany
they remove the desperation part of living in a new country
like an Afro Fest or an AmaPiano Music Festival
and once in a while
there is a large community of Ghanaians
and often when I visit an Afro shop
form relationships with them
tell me what's your experience like
a once in a while thing
South Africans generally emigrate for vibes
who own restaurants
because when you arrive
that is inviting the entire Ghanaian community
the high crime stats
until they've materialized
where I buy my hair product
South Africans do not prioritise
so I'm gonna touch on two or three of them
and we get to know each other
now all of these factors
or at least skeptical of them
WhatsApp group
I'm a South African
like Miss Nigeria
and have an opportunity to pursue their studies in a foreign country
you have a job
or you're warned against accepting a plate of food
this is something that South Africans just don't do
forming a community with other South Africans abroad
and I think there's several reasons for it